staying in germany a german woman who
joined the islamic state group has been
sentenced to 10 years in prison for
letting a yazidi girl die of thirst a
german court found the woman guilty of
two crimes against humanity in the form
of enslavement
she and her former husband had kept the
five-year-old yazidi girl as a slave
chained up
and let her die in extremely hot
conditions
all right we're going to talk at our
political correspondent thomas sparrow
who has been tracking uh the case for us
uh this is a very disturbing case uh
thomas but
tell us a little bit more about the
circumstances of this little girl's
death and the sentencing of the women
who we can only refer to as jennifer w
for privacy reasons
it is very disturbing indeed but it's
also very significant it's been
described as one of the first
convictions anywhere in the world
related to the islamic state group's
persecution of the yasidi community so
certainly from that perspective very
important we're talking concretely here
about jennifer w who was born in the
german state of lower saxony who
converted to islam in 2013 then moved to
iraq and 2016
was then deported back to germany and
now this court in munich has convicted
her not only of belonging to the islamic
state group but also of aiding and
abetting attempted murder attempted war
crimes and crimes against humanity in
particular for failing to intervene in
the death of this small child so
certainly very disturbing but also very
important
it's certainly a circumstance that is
being followed closely by those who are
interested in the way the islamic state
group dealt with the yasidi community
thanks for that thomas
now more than 1 000 people have traveled
from germany to syria and iraq
to join islamist groups since 2012. more
than a quarter of them are women many
who left are now back in germany and to
to talk about such is returnees and
speccard is with me now she is the
director of the international center for
the study of violent extremism and she
joins me uh from the maldives um welcome
to dw perhaps let's begin with um you
know the note that my colleague thomas
ended on can you talk to us a little bit
about what you know regarding
how the so-called islamic state views
the yazidi people
we know that is killed thousands of
yazidi people including this little girl
who became a slave in fact the u.n
caused a genocide
sure hello christian
[Music]
i asked saw the yazidis as devil
worshipers and
they took their women and children as
slaves and enslaved them
but i think the most important thing for
your case is how jennifer w got caught
she was a rejourney that uh
your country believed was innocent in
the beginning but
it's the perfect example of people that
are returned back to
europe
and
if they stay with is and brag about it
they will be caught and she was caught
by an fbi informant who she told the
story to and you have a real
excuse me yes you have a real hero your
federal prosecutor who brought her to
justice
and
back of course you're talking about this
case and how she was caught in
i i just wondered you you've spoken to
to hundreds of is um returnees like
jennifer w
what concerns you
about them and the prosecutions that
they face
well
the real concern is that people like her
would come back um home and claim that
they're innocent which is what she did
do
but um she was stupid enough to continue
in it and to
brag to an informant
what she had done and the murder of this
little girl
and at her husband's hand those hands
although she didn't stop it
and basically incriminate herself and
for me this is a good example of how our
security forces work together and the
people that are in is that are guilty
that went to syria and came back will
get caught and they will get prosecuted
and your federal prosecutor claudia gorf
um dogged this case and she found the
mother of the child that was murdered
she brought everybody to court she found
a creative way to try the case
and this woman is going to pay the price
for what she did but that said there's
plenty of people that are somewhat
innocent i mean they went to is
believing that it was a state
they
didn't commit crimes they didn't murder
anyone i'm talking about women in
particular and certainly children
and we should be less fearful of
bringing them home knowing that our our
governments work together our government
and your government caught jennifer w
and our your prosecutors in particular
are fantastic claudia should be lauded
as a hero for trying this case so well
and i have one more question for you
very briefly if you can
what can you say about how important
this trial is of a returned female is
member in the global context
it's important because it shows that we
can bring these people to court
we can successfully try the ones that
did commit crimes
we can track down the evidence um it's
it takes hard work claudia worked really
hard on this case she turned over stones
that are very hard to turn over to find
the evidence and she brought it to court
and this woman is going to pay the price
for her crimes that said there's other
women that are relatively innocent that
need to be brought home and there's
certainly children that need to be
brought home and pity given to them that
they were full islamic state propaganda
but bravo for this case it shows the
world that we can bring these people
together
thank you very much and speaker of the
international center for the study of
violent extremism
you